we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail with a it's a it's an
interesting question take a listen
david just want to suggest
what would have happened if pence had
followed through
on what trump wanted him to do where do
you think we would be now
thank you right so trump wanted pence to
overturn the election
and pence said i can't do that i don't
have the power to do that
constitutionally and pence was of course
correct
let's play it out
let's say pence was willing to do
what trump wanted him to do which is
when arizona tries to say
our delegates vote for joe our electors
vote for joe biden
when michigan tries to say
our electors vote for joe biden mike
pence what they wanted pence to do was
to say no
these are in dispute
we are instead going to let a different
slate of electors vote instead of seven
republicans or or seven democrats or
however many it was from arizona we're
gonna let these seven republicans vote
instead and they vote for trump uh it
never would have worked
it never would have worked those
alternate slates of electors
they
let's see how i can explain this
determining who the rightful electors
are is not something that goes
from the senate from the house from the
senate you know the house of
representatives from the from congress
to the states
the states decide who are the electors
and send them to dc
so
if arizona
had seven republicans get together and
say we are the electors which happened
it happened in arizona
uh mike pence doesn't actually have the
right
to recognize any other particular people
so it would have gone nowhere now it
would have caused chaos i do believe
that if mike pence tried
to do that it would not have worked joe
biden would still be president today but
it would have riled up some trumpists to
such a degree because they would have
gotten into their head that it was
possible for pence to do it that the
riots likely would have been
dramatically worse and maybe would have
even lasted for days that's my sense let
me know what you think would have
happened if pence tried to do it make
sure you are a member so that you get
access instantly to the bonus show world
famous award-winning bonus show awards
we give out sure but awards nonetheless
sign up right now at joinpakman.com and
you can use the coupon code wow 22 to
save big off of a membership